In 3D computer graphics, we usually use a Cartesian Coordinate System. In this
system, we have an origin and three direction vectors called x, y, and z. The
origin is some fixed point in space whose location everyone agrees on. This
point can be anything. I could build a world based on the location of our
surveyor's marker, a dot drawn on a tablet, or a reference point is simply
imagined. For example, if I'm designing a great new teapot, I don't really care
where the rest of the world is located. So, I can state that my origin is just a
point in empty space. I might then build a the teapots model so that this origin
point is in the center of the bottom of the teapot. Here's a prettier view since
I want you to see the 3D coordinates better. The three direction vectors define
the axes of the coordinate system. They are normally each perpendicular to the
other. That is, the angle here, here and here are all each 90 degrees. It's
possible to define a coordinate system with axes that are not perpendicular but
this is rarely done in practice. For example, finding the distance between two
points becomes a tricky concept when the axes are not mutually perpendicular.
Given an origin and three vectors, we can then define the location of any point
in space with a triprelative numbers. For example, this point has a triprelative
2, 3 and 4, as it's two units along the x, three along the y, and four along the
z. 3D vectors are described by a similar coordinate system, except that the
origin is not needed. A vector describes a motion, which again can be described
by three numbers. That is, it describes how far to move to get from one point to
another. However, this movement is not fixed in any particular location in
space. To understand the difference, think about time. A specific time is like a
point. An amount of time is like a vector. It specifies a duration, but no
starting time is given.